what do you think of justin timberlake's
new side hustle he's apparently working
at target these days
i saw that i got the speaker in the
drink what else did you get yeah just a
piece of gum i love that he he played uh
with whoever that was because it was
really funny yeah breakers
you got icebreakers
speaking of side hustles lance is loving
his latest gig guest hosting bachelor in
paradise he'll appear in two more
episodes it's gonna be me
popped out singing it's gonna be me
i was like oh my god it's amazing sorry
i totally believe that of course
i bet you're dead it's gonna be may i
was contracted for that of course you
know you had to do something an
in-string fun had to affect it
[Music]
is this a role that would interest you
permanently for the long run have they
talked to you about it they've not asked
me and of course that's going to depend
on bachelor nation out there you know
i'm a part of bash nate so i get i
understand how volatile we can get and
we're very opinionated but i mean yes of
course it'd be a dream come true to be
able to host a show like that
now there is another hosting gig that is
open right now and that is the role of
jeopardy host any interest in that
project unfortunately i'm more of a
wheel of fortune guys so when pat sajak
retires give me a call but no one wants
to see me in that jeopardy host spot you
ever need a vanna white for you know
your pets say jack honey i got you
wow
in the meantime lance is busy preparing
for fatherhood he and hubby michael
turchin announced in june they're
expecting twins a boy and a girl via a
surrogate girl it is it is crazy at this
house so hopefully we'll have the
nursery done by the time they get here
if they come early we're in trouble you
know they're twins so we we know they'll
come early our due date's november but
they'll definitely come before halloween
which i'm excited about because i am a
huge halloween freak and i need
halloween babies
[Music]